you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is Game
three of four between Takara Nakamura
and the world's top chess engine
stockfish but with an interesting
condition Nakamura of course is without
an engine in this one and stockfish is
without an H pawn so it's already quite
interesting to try and come up with some
strategy from the initial position
because I don't know if this is so bad
of a pond to not have of course it's
going to still be an advantage to white
but already having a rook active will
make a quick castling maybe not so
appealing on the white side and black of
course will maybe not be so quick to
want to castle himself since it would
take a rock off of this half open file
castling kingside that is so with that
said one interesting ID on the white
side maybe to try and open up the
position in the center welcomed central
pawn exchanges and try to maybe get it
to a point where if the position does
open up in the center this King Ani 8
will be vulnerable and forced to one
side of the board or the other okay
so game kicks off in this one with E 4
by Nakamura c5 I'm not quite sure what
we're supposed to call this I guess we
could still say it's a Sicilian tonight
f6 Knight c3 knight c6 d4 okay an open
position just like it Sicilian version
akov we're going into without this H
pawn of course I had wondered about
maybe this Bishop g5 move at some point
since there isn't an H pawn around to
try and kick the Bishop from g5 but
instead we go for night b5 d6 Knight to
d5 Knight takes pawn takes I wonder
about something else even at this point
wonder if a for was an interesting idea
trying to keep things closed if a
six-night a form and trying this idea
something we would see just an irregular
you know position with still an age pot
on the board but okay we go in this
direction instead after d6 it's 95
Knight takes pawn takes 97 c4 Knight f5
Bishop d3 giving up the Bishop Queen a4
is threatening some discoveries
discovered well actually would be a
double check with 92 c7 Bishop d7 is
there to defend Bishop Queen to b4
pressure on d6 Queen the b8 does two
things defends d6 and eventually gets in
this b5 advance this night will be
kicked in short order so Bishop e3 the
knight is kicked b5 break is in takes
series of exchanges and with that the
Queen's are off this is an end this is
an end game and white is up upon and
will soon be looking to create a passed
pawn on the a file so as it turns out
this King will not be vulnerable this
rook can maybe even think about one day
getting active in this way something
along the fourth-ranked or maybe
targeting this d5 pawn which lacks pawn
support so maybe he's well maybe we can
file this pawn under the overextended in
in an overextended category but first
okay King e2 king d7 neither side really
does well to castle just removing the
king up keeping the King centralized b3
is setting up an a4 advance we do have
that and after rook takes we have rook
on H to see a notice how black would not
be so quick to take like this because
eventually what we have is the position
more simplified and an ideal position
for the white rook right behind this
passed pawn I believe this would be a
much much more simple position to play
of course and keep in mind without this
H pawn around these pawns can eventually
force through another pass pawn another
pass
Brooke pond okay we're not quite there
because after rook takes a for its rook
h2c ain't trying to get active on maybe
white second-ranked or even one day
playing to the fifth-ranked to pick up
the pawn
not quite yet of course because of the
bishop but nevertheless getting the rook
to a more active square white doubles
work on a to b8 again not so quick to do
this because he's getting ready to roll
that a pawn he'll be very fast rook b8
instead rook c4 pair of rooks come off
and now we're up to a7 King to d8 and
Bishop to d2 and the pawn is picked up
was there something better at this point
right here instead of the check what is
maybe another try
rook a3 but notice with rook a3 this is
allowing rook b5 Bishop d2 this pawn is
gone so it's not so easy it may it may
seem like why did why did white give up
this beep on but notice
well this pawn is maybe being vulnerable
the d5 pawn you know this is a very
defensive position for the rook and this
is a super active position for the rook
that will get a pawn back so it's not as
easy to convert this this is just a tool
to active a rook if something else is
tried instead of rook to a3 let's say
rook to b1 well okay it's the same story
isn't it
rope to b5 you cannot defend both pawns
so as it turned out in this game there
really wasn't even though white was up
the pond there wasn't a way at least in
Nakamura's eyes that he was able to
convert this so easily what was tried is
rook a 7 and pretty much at this point
we had a back and forth and this one
ended much sooner than game 2 with a
draw by repetition of position we just
had that back and forth with rook e8 to
a 7 constantly giving checks there's not
no progress that black can make and
I see very little progress that y can
make in this position either it's
reading have the evaluation up on the
side here it's reading as zeros so a
drawn result feel free to share how what
you think of the result is this
something that you think is good or bad
without the H pon that's also very
interesting which pond maybe do you
think is the worst one to start out
without feel free to share any of your
thoughts on this interesting variation
of chess and from this game three and
also at the end of this video I'll
provide a link to Game four where
Nakamura is yet again playing against
doc fish only this time with stock fish
playing as black without a beep on so
that's all for this video I hope you
enjoyed it take care bye vision b7
preparing now to fee and kettle black
now strikes right at the moment where
this rook is vulnerable on takes Knight
takes Knight takes Queen takes white is
there in time to defend the knight